pour 200 mille abonnés qui est l'auteur
de la doctrine des chances réponse à
isaac newton
réponse b abraham de moivre réponse et
daumas baïse ou réponse des pierre simon
laplace
[Musique]
alors parmi vous j'imagine qu'il y en a
qui connaissent la bonne réponse à cette
question notamment ceux qui ont lu la
formule du savoir et ont une excellente
mémoire mais je parlais que la plupart
d'entre vous ont beaucoup d'incertitudes
vis-à-vis de cette question il est ainsi
probable que si vous deviez répondre à
ce questionnaire à choix multiples qcm
vous répondriez un peu au hasard et ça
malheureusement c'est devenu assez
courant vu que les qcm ont le bon goût
d'être faciles à corriger
on a tendance à les privilégier dans de
nombreux examens un qcm par opposition à
un examen classique
c'est un énorme gain de temps d'énergie
et surtout d'argent
et oui car les correcteurs il faut les
payer mais ce n'est pas tout du côté
étudiants un qcm
en un sens c'est aussi plus juste qu'une
dissertation après tout la manière dont
les professeurs note les dissertations
contient pas mal d'aléatoire et c'est
pas thibault qui va me contredire
et ça c'est gênant parce que la note de
l'étudiant risque alors de dépendre de
quel professeur corrige la copie de
l'étudiant voire pire encore de si le
professeur a bien mangé avant de
corriger la copie des étudiants donc les
qcm ont des avantages vis-à-vis des
examens traditionnels ils ont toutefois
également de nombreux inconvénients
en premier lieu ils empêchent de tester
la réelle compréhension du sujet par
l'étudiant en s'entraînant sur des qcm
type un étudiant peut ainsi parfois
apprendre à avoir une bonne note à
l'examen sans avoir à faire l'effort de
comprendre le contenu du cours au
programme de l'examen et ça c'est
d'ailleurs un cas particulier ce qu'on
appelle la loi de good rare qui peut
être plus importante des lois de
l'économie et qui a des conséquences
critique pour la manière de structurer
dans son organisation et de programmer
les intelligences artificielles
mehdi et moi en parlant d'ailleurs
longuement dans un livre sorti récemment
en second lieu les qcm ont le mauvais
goût de donner lieu à des injustices a
posteriori en effet le fait que les
étudiants répondent parfois au hasard
fait qu'un étudiant à obtenir une
meilleure note qu'un étudiant b alors
que l'étudiant à a mieux compris le
court que l'étudiant b les qcm sont
ainsi un peu à mi chemin entre un examen
adéquat et une loterie enfin et
peut-être surtout les qcm donne aux
étudiants la mauvaise habitude de juste
deviner et de choisir une réponse les
habitués à ces étudiants à raisonner de
manière déterminée stick et à ne pas
faire particulièrement attention au
degré de confiance en la validité de
leurs réponses alors pour corriger ces
défauts des qcm certains proposent
parfois de pénaliser les mauvaises
réponses aux qcm
voilà qui peut ainsi motiver les
étudiants à admettre qu'ils ne sont pas
assez sûrs d'eux et qui leur vaut mieux
s'abstenir de répondre plutôt que de
tenter une réponse au hasard clairement
ça c'est bien mieux que d'encourager
systématiquement les étudiants à deviner
une unique réponse mais aujourd'hui je
vais essayer de vous convaincre qu'il ya
mieux
et même beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'une manière de
transformer les qcm en examen qui n'ont
pas les trois grands défauts des qcm
classique
disons qu'ils les ont moins et l'astuce
pour y arriver comme vous l'avez sans
doute deviné c'est de rendre les qcm
bayésiens alors petit aparté historique
les qcm by zahia ou été inventé par un
professeur d'informatique de la
bourgogne de younes et les eagles
university bon en fait ces universités
de bourgogne à dijon
ce professeur c'est olivier beaulieu qui
est d'ailleurs aussi youtube heures
après avoir lu mon livre la formule du
savoir olivier m'a envoyé un email ou au
milieu d'un tas de remarquer très
intéressante
il propose une nouvelle façon d'examiner
les étudiants
je cite imaginons maintenant un qcm
bayésiens avec pour simplifier dans un
premier temps des questions ayant deux
réponses possibles
au lieu de choisir une des réponses les
étudiants donnent leur crédence ont
chacune d'elles
ça c'est vraiment la vulgarisation cents
vols à son meilleur
honnêtement ça se voit peut-être mais je
suis terriblement fiers de cet échange
l'idée qu'un livre que j'ai écrit puisse
susciter des réflexions de cette qualité
franchement waouh
merci olivier oui car en poussant l'idée
d'olivier un peu plus loin je me suis
rendu compte d'à quel point elle est
brillante
ainsi cette fois au lieu de choisir une
réponse parmi
les quatre réponses proposées l'étudiant
devra signer des probabilités à chacune
des réponses
donc si vous êtes l'étudiant il ne
connaissait absolument rien vous mettrez
sans doute 25% à chacune des réponses
alors que si vous êtes sûr que l'auteur
du livre et newton vous mettrez 100 % à
newton et 0% au reste mais bien sûr vous
pouvez avoir des réponses plus nuancées
comme 10% 20% à 30% et 40% alors je vous
invite à mettre pause et à écrire vos
réponses probabiliste en commentaires ou
si vous avez peur de vous tromper
publiquement je vous invite à écrire vos
réponses probabiliste sur un bout de
papier et faites-le vraiment c'est
vraiment instructif d'essayer de le
faire ça vous évitera de dire après coup
je le savais alors que nous ne savait
peut-être pas alex us encore dix
secondes pour mettre pause qui est
l'auteur de la doctrine des chances
réponse à isaac newton
réponse b à branne de moivre réponse et
thomas paine et réponses des pierre
simon laplace
alors si vous vous y connaissez un petit
peu en histoire des sciences vous savez
peut-être qu'ils aient à clinton n'a
jamais vraiment parlé de probabilités
que de moivre a été le premier à
explorer des versions du théorème
centrale limite un tournant fondamental
des probabilités que baise s'est
intéressé aux probabilités mais étaient
frileux à l'idée de publier et que la
place est le premier grand probabiliste
de l'histoire des sciences et c'est le
cas peut-être que vous alignerez des
probabilités 1% 45% 4 % et 50 % aux
quatre réponses
ce serait alors ces probabilités qu'ils
formeraient votre réponse
bon si c'est ce que vous avez répondu
bien bon vous n'avez pas eu tout à fait
juste il se trouve que la bonne réponse
est la réponse b abraham de moivre fun
fact en 1685 de moivre a fui la france
suite à la révocation de l'édit de
nantes pour rejoindre du coup la sociale
society à londres où il a eu la chance
de devenir pote avec un certain de
newton et c'est là bas qu'il publia son
livre sur les probabilités et c'est un
livre vraiment important puisqu'il
influencera pas mal notre cher la place
qui lui publiera des travaux
révolutionnaires la place hockey donc si
vous avez répondu 1% 45% 4 % et 50 %
alors vous vous êtes trompés mais vous
n'êtes pas non plus trop planté puisque
vous avez quand même donné 45 % à la
bonne probabilité est ce à dire que vous
êtes trompé de 55 % du coût est ce que
le nombre de points que vous avez marqué
à ce qcm devrait être 45 points non pas
vraiment et vous voyez pourquoi pourquoi
est ce qui serait une mauvaise idée
donné 45 points un étudiant qui aurait
pondu 45% à la bonne réponse
allez pour vous aider pour avoir des
pistes de réflexion je vais mettre
quelques vignettes youtube autour de moi
vous aide
oui le groupe
façon de noter ce sont les incentives
que cela produit les étudiants finirait
alors peut-être par se rendre compte
qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à révéler leur
vraie crédence en fait dans notre cas un
étudiant qui aurait les crédences qu'on
a décrite aurait intérêt à parier 000
100%
en effet c'est lui ferait une espérance
de points égale à 50 points par
opposition aux 45,42 points obtenus en
moyenne pour une réponse honnête
autrement dit s'ils répondaient
constamment en exagérant la réponse
qu'il concerne la plus crédible à des
qcm du genre
l'étudiant gagneraient en moyenne plus
de points qu en décrivant sa vraie
incertitude et ça c'est vraiment pas
cool parce que sa garde pas mal des
mauvaises propriété de la notation
classique des qcm donc pour concevoir un
bon coussin bézian il faut aussi et
surtout que la notation du qcm s'assure
de donner line saint-yves aux étudiants
de raisonner de manière vraiment
bayésienne ce genre de notation ça
existe on parle de notation strictement
propre même si je trouve que la
terminologie est vraiment pas top et du
coup plutôt que de parler de notation
propre je vais parler de notation
incentive compatit bol ça c'est la
version en anglais ou en français
disons de notation pro honnêteté une
notation pro honnêteté c'est
littéralement une notation qui favorise
le net au t1 et alors il se trouve qu'il
existe plusieurs notation pro honnête au
thé comme la notation logarithmique où
la notation sphérique
mais la plus simple est peut-être la
plus adéquate c'est sans doute la
notation dit quadratique d'une certaine
manière
ici la bonne réponse était en fête 0 100
% 0 0 la notation quadratique consiste à
calculer un moins la somme des carrés
des erreurs autrement dit la note
ici serait 1 - 0 0 1 - 0 au quart et
0,45 moins un au carré plus 0,04 - 0 au
cari +0 5 - 0 au carré ce qui nous fait
approximativement 0,45
bien entendu un individu qui aurait
donné la bonne réponse est à dire les
probabilités 0 100 % 0 et 0 aurait gagné
un point
al'inverse un individu qui se trompent
leur est maximale mans par exemple si
donner des probabilités 100 % à 0 0 et 0
aurait gagné moins un point
autrement dit ils auraient perdu 1 point
enfin un individu complètement ignorants
aurait répondu 25% à chacune des
réponses
le nombre de points qu'il aurait marqué
et le résultat de ce calcul qui est égal
à 0,25 point est donc une on remarque
que l'on peut faire c'est qu'un individu
qui marque le nombre de points négatifs
est un individu qui d'une certaine
manière se trompent plus qu'un individu
ignorants et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que ça montre qu
individu raisonne en fait mal et en
particulier son raisonnement n'est pas
suffisamment probabiliste mais du coup
notre étudiant qui lui a essentiellement
réussi à écarter de réponse à marquer
bien plus de points qu'un étudiant
ignorants pour rappel notre étudiant
avait marqué 0 45 point et ça ça permet
bel et bien de quantifier sa supériorité
épistémique cet étudiant qui a réussi à
écarter de réponse se situe bien entre
un individu ignorants et un individu
savant voilà qu'il suggère que les cette
approche permet vraiment de noter les
étudiants de manière plus juste
chaque étudiant reçoit ainsi une note
qui correspondent davantage à son état
de connaissances et ça c'est chouette
mais en fait c'est loin d'être le plus
chouette avec le cusems bézian la
propriété fondamentale des qcm bayésiens
pro honnêteté c'est surtout d'encourager
l'honnêteté intellectuelle dans la
description de notre état de
connaissances et ça à bien y réfléchir
c'est une propriété est extrêmement rare
dans nos sociétés nous encouragent
souvent à prendre une position et à
défendre cette position comme si notre
vie en dépendait
on favorise si souvent celui qui a un
avis tranché et usent et abusent de
rhétorique de moqueries et d'appels à la
meute pour la défendre
malheureusement le doute et
l'incertitude légitimes sont rarement
valoriser parce que les récompenses
qu'on donne ne nous invite pas à
réfléchir en ces termes les tcm
bayésiens change complètement la donne
il nous encourage au contraire à des
clercs l'étendue de notre ignorance et
pénalise littéralement le bullshit leur
propriété de pro honnêteté peut nous
habituer à une tout autre ijen
épistémique or comme l'expliqué si bien
jules haag élèves on veut mieux
réfléchir la première étape est
d'aligner les récompenses que l'on a
avec les incentives à être
intellectuellement honnête les qcm
bézian semble être un outil
indispensable pour y arriver
enfin et peut-être surtout les qcm
bayésiens semble nous habituer à
développer des raisonnements
probabiliste il nous invite à quantifier
notre ignorance et à la révéler
publiquement
nous motive aussi à manipuler des
probabilités pour décrire adéquatement
cette ignorance ce qui semble vital pour
réduire nos risques d'excès de confiance
alors bien sûr les qcm badiane ne
résolvent pas tous les maux de
l'examination il persistera des
étudiants qui parviennent à réussir
leurs examens sans comprendre le cours d
injustice dû à la chance et des
étudiants qui devine sans réfléchir
cependant les qcm bayésiens semble
donner des incitatifs qui réduisent
chacun de ses effets tout en gardant la
bonne propriété d'être faciles à
corriger de conduire à la même notation
d'un correcteur à l'autre bref les qcm
bayésiens me semble avoir toutes sortes
de propriété fantastique
j'adorerais voir leur déploiement en
pratique donc si vous êtes enseignant ou
si vous connaissez un enseignant
j'aimerais vraiment vous encourager ou
vous encourager à encourager d'autres à
tester des qcm barisien sur vos
étudiants et à me faire des retours
positifs ou négatifs sur le court terme
je doute que ce soit révolutionnaire
mais à force de s'habituer et d'habitués
notre entourage à raisonner en termes
probabiliste il me semble qu'on
progressera tous grandement notre
compréhension et dans notre maîtrise du
maïs à nice mme et ça ça semble critique
pour penser plus juste et pour débattre
de manière plus productive la fois on a
parlé des croyances orphelines et rp
partagent une croyance orpheline qui l'a
donc fait station avait cessé toujours
très cool de voir des gens partager des
cas où ils ont mal raisonné et l'exemple
que prend rp c'est quelque chose qu'il a
entendu à propos d'un individu et du
coup à cause de ce qu'ils avancent de
cette rumeur
il a eu un mauvais préjugés par rapport
à cet individu mais se trouve qu'en fait
la rumeur concernés quelqu'un d'autre
mais il a gardé quelques pas au fond de
lui sans être parfaitement conscient
peut être ce mauvais sentiments cette
mauvaise a priori envers l'individu en
question et ça c'est un truc qui me
réussit très très souvent de me dire
atteint quelque chose qui a pas assez
avec cette personne et ensuite de menton
qu'en fait ce qu'ils allaient passer
quelque chose que je croyais avoir
entendu au sujet de cette personne
j'ai compris après coup que la rumeur
était fausse hooker en fait elles
conservent pas cette personne en
particulier et plus généralement ceux ci
montrent vraiment le problème des
premières impressions en tant qu on a
une première impression de quelqu'un la
première fois qu'on rencontre a tout de
suite les premiers trucs qui implique eu
un certain sentiment à tort à cette
personne est malheureusement les fois
suivantes ouvrant contre cette personne
est possible qu'on oublie pourquoi on a
eu ce genre de sentiment et peut-être
potentiellement pourquoi est ce que la
cause est dépassée justifié peut-être
que la personne qui est stressé par
exemple mais on oublie cette cause et du
coup on reste juste sur la mauvaise
première impression que l'on a de cet
individu sans forcément méditer
suffisamment devient cette première
impression
ça me paraît vraiment être un excellent
exemple et j'ai un peu honte de dire que
j avais pas pensé au moment de préparer
la vidéo la semaine dernière paule
amblard plus fait la remarque que dans
nos modèles internes
on a souvent des boucles de causalité
donc typiquement plus je fais de vidéos
plus il ya de gens qui me suivent mais
puis agent des eaux qui me suivent plus
je vais avoir une motivation pour faire
plus de vidéos du coup là on a une
boucle de rétroaction et ça en termes de
réseaux bayésiens c'est assez
catastrophique puisque pas mal d analyse
classique et des réseaux buy vient ne
s'applique pas à des réseaux parisiens
qui auraient se voir deux boucles en
fait par défaut souvent dans la
littérature on va considérer des graves
de causalité dit à cycliques
c'est-à-dire sans cycles sens en boucle
et ça ça simplifie grandement leur
analyse dans le même genre tout le cas
de la théorie des jeux où c'est des gens
qui intéresse avec d'autres gens du coup
l'interaction est scellé stratégique bas
chacun réagit cela la stratégie de
l'autre et du coup une boucle de
rétroaction où chacun réagit à la
stratégie que l'autre l'autre al jala
des stratégies et ainsi de suite
du coup dans pas mal de modèles on en
fait des boucles de causalité est très
probants dans le cerveau n'a également
des boucles de causalité et le truc avec
les boucles de causalité sais que ça
peut conduire à des incohérences compter
qu'il ya souvent des phénomènes assez
exponentielle qui émerge et que du coup
on a beaucoup de trucs qui explosent et
du coup elles deviennent plus tous
fiables
bref pour avoir des modèles qu'ils
analysent assez bien on a tendance à
éviter ces boucles de causalité est une
fondation d'enlever ses boucles de
causalité servient a d'une certaine
manière déplié ses boucles de causalité
en imaginant qui a plusieurs versions
par exemple
ma motivation et plusieurs versions de
mou nombre d'abonnés par un homme qui
évolué au cours du temps
donc si on déplie ce graphe de causalité
en fait ce qui se passe c'est plutôt que
le nombre d'abonnés que j'ai un instant
donné influence ma productivité au temps
t + 1 alors que la productivité au temps
t va influencer mon nombre d'abonnés aux
tentes et plus sain et du coup en
dépliant ainsi les boucles de causalité
on obtient un nouveau un graphe
acyclique est d'ailleurs ce que je
présente là c'est quelque chose dont on
a déjà parlé dans un épisode pour les
réseaux de neurones où on a vu que les
réseaux de neurones dits récurrents sont
en fait équivalent d'un point de vue
calculatoire à des réseaux de neurones
beaucoup plus grands qui ont été ainsi
déplié elle espère qu'ils avaient mené
cet épisode et que c'est ça a cliqué
quelque part aussi de plus en plus
souvent je pense que c'est cul c'est une
balle d'un ça peut vraiment changer la
manière dont vont réfléchir parce que
généralement nous habitions voir ce que
j'aime montrer this way ça décolle un
petit peu sur deux choses ceci dit une
connerie comme on fait souvent c'est que
ça mène toujours les gens à parler d'une
certaine manière et on a tendance à
penser que parier essaimage et bien la
semaine prochaine je vais défendre la
thèse opposée
je vais essayer de vous convaincre du
fait que parler c'est super bien
en parlant du poker un jeu d'argent avec
modération mais tout ça je vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez réalité a
commenté à l'appartenance et vous
abonner pour le concepteur huit jeunes
vers ce type app world et j'espère
qu'ils iront à la prochaine fois
[Musique]
oh
ça aide
[Musique]